the southern border first it was a
crisis then it wasn't than it was what
could it be now this president just used
the backdrop of the Oval Office to
manufacture a crisis right now we have a
crisis at our southern border some
question if there is a crisis at all as
the president has claimed we do have a
crisis at the border and intelligence
official tells CNN quote no one is
saying this is a crisis except then we
sit down instantly and start negotiating
and into this border security crisis but
no sign of the national emergency that
the president has been talking about as
a matter of fact it's pretty tranquil
down here crisis no crisis crisis the
media is like your dumb friend you asked
to step out of the car to see if the
blinkers are working yeah it's working
not working working not working happy
make sense of this journalism these days
is just another form of hysteria a
cynical person might think that if the
press can't pin the crisis on you then
the crisis doesn't exist meanwhile we
see the crisis with our own eyes we see
the Coyotes as people who traffic and
suffering the media just sees them as
goofy colorful tour guides that's a
result of childish denial
it'll make you say anything other than
the truth stuff that borders on the
obscene the border crisis is a long-term
problem that makes problem solvers in
the short term look like the bad guys
you're the parent threatening to take
away the kids avocados meanwhile the
Dems and media don't know what a crisis
actually is they're like a sailor saying
his leaking boat works great until it's
in the water that's how they see the
border it works just fine until
someone's crossing it now you have
thousands crossing daily and the media
reverts to its usual amnesia it's a
crisis again everyone this migrant
situation is called a crisis but you
know what that word is overused and
doesn't do the situation justice we're
gonna show you what's happening here
it's not easy to see let's shine a light
on what is obvious what do you say let's
dad's would expect for two years they
were screaming that we had a Russian
plant in the White House never
contemplating their hysterias effects
thankfully smarter people kept them from
destroying the country even as they
destroyed their own credibility that's
the bigger crisis a failed media trying
to tell you what matters so Kenny a
child's view is something bad is
happening now let's fix it an adult view
is what's happening now happened before
and can happen later so we need a
long-term fix isn't that what this is
really about yes that's a that's a good
way of framing it and Congress is
supposed to be the adult Congress is
supposed to be the body that looks at
long-term effects of immigration and
perhaps allowing people in the country
who want to work and want to help our
economy and who want to fill some of the
labor spots that are incredibly tight
right now unemployment is is very very
low and we do need help from our friends
from the south from Central America and
Mexico having said that when you have
people who are in limbo they're they're
torn between two countries they want to
go to the land of the free they want to
go to America they want to help their
families they want to escape places that
are run by drug cartels but they can't
so what do they do they rush for the
exits just like if you are in a concert
hall and it catches on fire you're gonna
have a stampede and people are going to
get hurt and that is what's happening
here and Congress is supposed to be the
body that makes sure there are fire
codes and fire extinguishers and plenty
of exits so people aren't trampled to
death
it's excellent analogy you know Jesse I
believe that she might have done a
better analogy than your horse won from
last week you still remember it I do you
know the Dems realize you can't create a
country of great free stuff without a
container that holds the free stuff and
that's kind of what a border is that's
not what this is about Greg oh damn it
this is about the Democrats wanted to
turn Texas blue if Texas is blue
Republicans will never win another
presidential election you won't even
have to have a conversation about the
electoral college it's over forget about
it they'll win for the rest of eternity
so they don't have a solution for the
border because they don't want a
solution they want open borders only a
few of them will say that they don't
have the political courage they'll hide
behind things like it's not a crisis you
know let's get some more beds for the
detainees it's not true have they even
gone down to get a briefing from the
Border Patrol have they ever even gone
to Mexico or to Central America to talk
to their counterparts do they want to
change the detention policy the asylum
policy the catch and release policy no
we've listened to video on this show of
Border Patrol agents say it's like a
United Nations we're catching crossing
Albanians Pakistanis they're human
traffickers they're ms-13 they're
gangbangers they're literally bringing
children who they don't know with them
to cross the border because they minute
they cross and set foot we have to catch
and release them and say in two years
we'll see what the immigration hearing
but they don't show up that's not a
country that's a lawless nation why do
you agree I'm sure you do that that's
it's blue I love hysterics but I mean
that's why you can't solve this problem
because people will say just
off-the-wall things and you've got
gangbangers and murders and terrorists
from Southeast Asia I mean it's just not
true here's the thing no gang no come on
this is like Trump yesterday Trump says
Trump's makes this oh you know what if I
close the border no impact Mitch
McConnell and the Republicans had to
tell mr. president even the Chamber of
Commerce had tell mr. president that's
gonna damage the American economy don't
do it stupid and it's just like you know
he goes off and he says oh people
applying for asylum only 3% show up for
the hearings mr. president it's closer
to 90% so he does things like separate
kids from family Obama no Obama had
enough companied miners this are
families and so when he uses the term
crisis he uses things like oh we're
being invaded this is an invasion it's a
military issue
No what you've got is what Kennedy
described families who say you know what
it's getting harder with this guy's
rhetoric and this guy's threats about a
wall and so we're gonna try to put our
children in better position
to have economic prosperity we'd like to
come maybe we should go now because
Crump's rhetoric is so divisive what all
right let me get Dana do you believe
that it's Trump's divisive rhetoric
that's enticing people to America I your
point that his threat to close down the
border is the whole thing the wall the
port I think it does send a message to
people if you're coming you'd better go
now so I will see if that happens we
know that that happened with Obama
remember when I can't remember what the
decision was but then all of a sudden
you had all of these migrants coming
because they were like oh my gosh
something's gonna change so they rush
you could argue the opposite sure that's
the thing it's a pointless that way but
you're to go back to your original point
about the adult so the issue really is
laws and a court decision the law being
the asylum piece the court decision
being the one that you can't hold
children for longer than twenty days and
so the point that if so let's just
saying that it's true that ninety
percent show up for their hearing but if
a million people are coming in a year or
more so we had a hundred thousand and
March you start that starts to get
that's a pretty big number and the
president's approval numbers with
Hispanics is on the rise mm-hmm why is
that because they don't like this and I
don't think it's gonna help them in
Texas the Democrats in Texas or Arizona
or anywhere else
why are we having more actually a Latino
person is going to automatically vote
demo well then it's the truth is it's
not true that it doesn't happen and the
president's numbers are up with
Hispanics all right we got to we got to
go did you want to say they don't vote
Republican yeah oh all right